Speaker 2: Let's go to Bite from Deltona. Bite.
Welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 1: Thanks, David. I just
want to start by saying that
I am sort of a fellow by cultural denizen
of the world. I was I have split time
from the time I was 0 to 18 between Peru and
the United States. And the reason I mentioned I
think it's important because when you do get your
education outside of the United States, of course,
you kind of, you know, pull yourself out of the
indoctrination stream. You know, the cultural,
you know, indoctrination and social conditioning
that takes place. If you experience the American
educational system from sure, you know, grade,
you know, kindergarten through high school.
So I just kind of want to throw that out. I wanted
to get your take on an idea that I had based on a
letter that I received from Marco Rubio with
regards to abortion. Okay. The thing that he
states in his letter is that he is defending the
rights of the 65 million unborn children that did
not get to experience the dream, the American
dream, because of the during the 50 years.
Speaker 2: Right. They were never.
Speaker 1: Born. In other words.
Right. Right. So he's defending their rights.
Now, I had a thought about possibly painting
them into a corner, because technically
speaking, you know, from their position,
my understanding would be that they are they are
defending the rights of the fetus to be born.
Speaker 2: Yeah. And here's the thing I think it's
important to mention, they would say that it's
a person already and that's why it has rights.
Speaker 1: Right. So. Exactly. But here's where
I'm going with this. Yes. Now, when we're
born, of course, we have a federal Social
Security number which basically establishes our
our identity. I personally think that we should
be able to legally argue in court that if the
states are going to defend the fetus, they would
be required to give that fetus an identification
number. And at that point in time also, of course,
state all the benefits that that fetus is
going to be and the host is going to receive
on the basis of that establishment of identity.
Speaker 2: Got it. Yes. I'm one step ahead of
you on this. I've got a number of different clips
you can find in which I point out this hypocrisy,
if you're talking about a person at conception,
should have a Social Security number, should
qualify for child support, should prevent
a mother. If if the pregnant mother is an
undocumented immigrant, she shouldn't be able to
be deported because it's already a person and it's
here in the United States. There's a whole list
of these. Your the concept is absolutely right.
And I've elaborated on it before.
Speaker 1: Okay. So you said that
you agree with that that that would
that would paint them into a corner?
Speaker 2: No. I mean, they'll come up
with they'll come up with some way out
of it. But I agree with you that
it exposes a hypocrisy for sure.
Speaker 1: Okay. All right. Well, thanks for your
comment on that. And sorry I missed that before,
but I started listening to you, you know, right
around the 2016 election or right before that.
Speaker 2: Appreciate it very much. Thank you for
the call. All right. Take it easy. All right. You,
too. Yeah, that's that's a very, very
astute observation, for sure. There are